on en parle moins mais en cette 27e
journée internationale du sida on
constate que le vih fait encore partie
de la réalité quotidienne de millions de
personnes à travers le monde ça dit
frédéric selon le rapport onu sida la
tendance est quand même à la baisse là
depuis quelques années une tendance
encourageante geneviève même si c'est
vrai lorsqu'on regarde le chiffre c'est
quand même assez impressionnant presque
37 millions de personnes à travers le
monde sont en fait on était vraiment
déclaré séropositif
par contre ce qui est intéressant de
voir c'est que c'est le nombre de
nouveaux cas détectés qui lui est en
baisse alors comment ça se passe à
travers le monde
et bien malheureusement c'est encore une
fois l'afrique subsaharienne c'est dans
cette région là qu'on trouve le plus
grand nombre de séropositifs ses presque
70 % de la population totale dans le
monde qui est infecté par ce virus donc
par contre 41% de moins de cas qui sont
détectés récemment ça c'est important
si on regarde également en amérique
latine là on est en à peu près un
million 700 mille 5 millions dans la
région asie pacifique
il ya deux régions en fait on voit une
hausse depuis le début des années 2000
c'est en europe de l'est et en asie
centrale en fait une augmentation de 30
% des nouveaux cas donc ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui inquiète
beaucoup onu sida enfin en europe de
l'ouest est chez nous en amérique du
nord à peu près stable donc 2 millions
400 mille enfin un mot sur le nombre de
décès quand on regarde les chiffres en
2000 en avait 1 million 600 mille
personnes qui sont décédées des suites
d'une maladie liée au sida 2005 on a
vraiment atteint un sommet de deux
millions et puis deux puis on peut dire
que ça descend regarder l'année dernière
un million deux cent mille personnes
sont décédées du sida parce qu'on sait
l'accès aux médicaments à ben quoi
augmente ce qui veut dire que les gens
vivent plus longtemps si effectivement
ce sont les fameuses antirétroviraux qui
permettent justement de pouvoir vivre
avec le vih quand on recevait un
diagnostic dans les années 80 c'était
quasiment un acte de condamnations à
mort maintenant on peut vivre avec le
vih donc près de 16 millions de
personnes ayant accès ses 84 % de plus
depuis 2010 ce n'est pas négligeable et
au pays quelle est la situation alors
selon le dernier chiffre qu'on vient de
de collecter il y aurait environ 75000
cas de personnes qui vivent avec le
fameux vih et une augmentation de près
de 10% depuis 2011 peut-être de
l'insouciance parce que quand on regarde
justement sur ces cas là il y aurait une
personne sur cinq qui ignore qu'il est
porteur du virus
enfin depuis le début de l'épidémie de
sida au canada il ya eu 26 mille décès
geneviève voilà qui fait le tour de la
question merci beaucoup frères inc